now let's get a little tight okay thank
you for sticking around and thanks to
organizer for giving me the last word so
I'm going to talk today I know I'm going
to talk about pricing this this talk is
a joint work with Jiang Shi who with my
PhD student and she's done of course all
the work I'm doing the talking and then
I'm going to talk about how to mobilize
to use computers
as a way to achieve more flexibility out
of the infrastructure that we currently
have so first of all why do we need
flexibility and this is kind of shows
rapid penetration of renewables
California is aiming actually already
achieved 33 percent renewable portfolio
standard by 2020 and that consists of
wind and solar and the problem is that
wind is very unpredictable until you get
this is called the spaghetti chart until
you get very close to real-time you
don't know how much you're going to get
furthermore it's negatively correlated
with load most of the wind blows at
night when we don't need it on the sole
on the solar side we have what you have
seen previously this is known as the
duck curve and that basically shows by
2020 that during the normal hours a lot
of the supply is going to be produced by
the Sun and that creates a ramp
sharp sharp ramps down and up and then
also it creates an over generation
problem and during the middle of the
middle of the day
so in order to deal with all that the
new the challenge the new challenge to
the system operator is that they need
flexible resources flexible resources
mix that can react quickly to adjust
electricity production to meet the sharp
changes in electricity and to produce
you know to react to net demand so this
is the you know we have ramping
requirements and we need flexible
resources and we need to mitigate the
over generation so the dark curve this
is them you know this is the original
load profile now during the day you
start to produce more and more solar so
the solar does it satisfies part of the
demand so this represents what you still
need you know the net load that needs to
be satisfied by the standard portfolio
of gas turbines and whatever you have so
the load - the solar is this so this
looks like a duck right looks like a
duck it quacks like a duck must be a
duck so so when so this is this is that
what gives a headache to the system
operator how to deal with those ramps
and how to you know to encourage
generators to respond because generators
in the United States have the
opportunity to either submit economic
bid or to submit a physical say I want
to produce that much during those hours
and they will pay for congestion so we
need some how to monetize to give them
an incentive to respond to signals and
economically that's why we pay them for
those generators that are capable to
move fast we want to encourage them to
move faster to install governors that is
going to enable them to move fast and
that's why we pay for
Bing capability so we create new
products that are going to encourage to
Hmong people to incentivize their
behavior to respond to the need of the
system operator now we can do it on the
demand side as well aim so these are the
challenges and there are different ways
to respond to them so first of all you
can have invest in more flexible
generators gas turbines can install
equipment that will enable them to go up
and down very fast and we can make the
transmission more flexible which is what
I'm going to talk in here in this talk
we can mobilize the main response these
are all the TLC's thermally
thermostatically-controlled law that we
can be incentivized to respond and
storage of course so those are different
ways to provide flexibility and as I
said we are going to focus on that part
which means that the transmission system
that traditionally has been considered
as a fixed asset you know a network with
capacity constraint actually has
embedded flexibility that we don't
utilize we don't utilize it because
there is no incentive to do that we also
don't utilize because doing that would
require a lot of computation that we
don't have but now we do have
computations so we can do that so we are
going to focus on two ways to make the
transmission assets more flexible one is
called topology control which means that
we are going now to dispatch the system
while at the same time controlling the
topology by switching lines in and out
of the network on an hourly basis
depending on the optimization now just
to show you why that can help the other
way is flexible line rating we can take
advantage of the fact that the
constraint on transmission lines are
really mostly thermal constraints that
try to prevent the sagging from the line
hitting the floor
it gets too warm but that happened there
is some thermodynamics the line doesn't
hit instantly so you can actually
operate it at a higher line rating if
you're only going to do it for a limited
amount of time and then you're going to
follow it by a period of cooling off so
that you it will have a chance to
recover so instead of having a fixed
constrain you can modify the constraint
to say you can actually control you have
more than one limit and you can control
that limit when you're going to enforce
the tight constrain when you do even
going to enforce the loose constrain for
how long that again makes the problem
more complicated mathematically but we
can do it
there are fax devices that I'm not going
to talk now because that's new equipment
that require a lot of investment so we
are going to focus on just trying to
mobilize the existing grid and try to
make it work perform more flexibly so
when let me start by topology control
topology control has been studied for
many years there is a wide literature on
that a week you can relieve abnormal
condition reduces main losses reduced
operating cost and you can the idea is
to utilize the assets that you already
have by without additional costs just
switching lines in and out that's a
relatively simple thing to do now we had
a big project on that aim but let me
first explain why that works so if you
have a three node system this is a
system generate or a generator B and
this is the load and we assume that all
the impedances on the reactor this
acceptance is the same and we have flow
constraint now if Kirk of law tell you
that every mega was generated here will
third of it will go this way the long
way and the 2/3 will go this way so you
can write a set of linear inequality
this is the you know the polyhedron that
is going to define the limits
on how much you can inject in generate
or be and how much you can inject in
generate array so now if I want to
supply 200 megawatts edge location see
this is the optimum point so I'm going
to this the optimization the the optimum
cost is going to be twenty thousand
dollars an hour 100 megawatt generated
at a thirty baby and fortieth be however
if I'm going to cut this line out now
this is the the polyhedron so now this
is the optimum point and now this
optimum point generates two hundred at a
fifty eight B and you reduce the cost to
fifteen so by cutting a line now this is
almost like the bare breast paradox in
transportation by cutting a line out we
actually reduce the cost of supplying
the demand now imagine that you have a
big network you can do it selectively
yes well why is the line there in the
first place for reliability reasons
because you trying to the system the
transmission system is built in
inherently with a lot of redundancy
because of well we do it for a short
time but in a large network we can
actually also enforce reliability and
reliability constrain usually unit in
and electricity is n minus one meaning
that if any line failed the system can
still sustain is support its load so we
can still satisfy we can impose that as
additional constraint I'm going to
abstract from some of the data in the
examples but but we we have done that we
have in fact a paper here M which is
anyway we have a paper that we do it n n
minus one so the idea is that you can
selectively cut lines out that you don't
all would you build them for for
redundancy you know it's almost like
having a four-wheel drive I mean you put
extra four-wheel drive so that you can
climb a high mountain but you're not
going to use all the four-wheel drive
when you go on the freeway that's
wasteful
so you disengage the four wheels that's
essentially the same idea so so this is
topology control this is actually done
in practice they you know if you look at
the operating manual at PJM m there they
have a whole lot as a list of lines that
can be switched out under different
conditions a New England a operating
procedure nineteen specifies two you
know cartel and cutting and
disconnecting lines as actions the
problem is that they don't optimize
those things in real time they do it
kind of it's a static protocol that you
follow and what we want to do is to me
do it more actively by using computation
so we actually got a project from arpa-e
in 2012 five million dollars was a joint
project Texas A&M Berkeley Arizona State
University and several other institution
to demonstrate the commercial viability
of topology control and we were shown
for example using data from PJM that
over a period we took a high load period
and we have shown that over that period
we could have saved a hundred million
dollars by curtailing one line at a time
just just one line the best line that
you can yes
well we can check stability and we
always do that but disability usually is
checked off line you don't doing the
transient em that that's a problem that
we we have considered that's possible
but then again we when we do that first
we propose lines to take out then we do
simulations like oh you always do when
you take actions to see what it will do
to the system and we have you do all
these online simulations and that's
something that we have considered so
this was a successful project and in
fact there is a consulting company but
tables associates who are still they got
follow up they trying to promote
software for doing that at the different
ISOs now what we want to do here is
different we we want to now demonstrate
how we can use topology control in the
framework of a two-stage stochastic
programming of unit stochastic unit
commitment we want to use the policy
control as a recourse action that is
going to give us a hedge against
different realizations of win supply so
the idea is that we formulate the
problem now as a two-stage stochastic
program to state stochastic program is
actually an idealized version of what
currently is being done in the market
they different ISO essentially do a
market solution a market implementation
of stochastic pro to state stochastic
programming by having a two settlement
system where you have a day head market
and then you have a real-time market and
the people in the day head market submit
bids anticipating the uncertainty and
then in the real-time market when the
uncertainty gets reserved then they have
a second bite of the Apple and they can
dispatch the change they adjust the
dispatch of their general dispatch their
generators so if you're trying to
represent that somehow a two-stage
stochastic program
is a good way to capture that it's kind
of you can think of the current
implementation as a crowd solution to a
two-stage stochastic programming so we
are going to consider a stochastic
programming in which a we allow topology
control in the second stage as a as a
recourse action against once you realize
the uncertainty in the wind forecast and
you know exactly what's going to happen
the way the system works currently is
that you have a they had determination
of which resources are going to be
dispatched and usually it's important
for some slow generator that take a long
time to warm up and then the more
flexible generators are being dispatched
very close to real-time there is a 15
minute market in fact and the slow
generators are dispatched very close to
that in order to provide the judgment
capability so in this framework we're
going you know so so essentially what we
have here is stage one where you are
committing the slow resources so the
decision variables in that here are
binary variables primarily because you
decide which generators are going to be
turned on and off then the Renewable you
get a realization of the uncertainty and
then in the second stage you commit and
adjust the output of both the fast and
the slow generators in response to a how
much renewable energy
you actually got mostly is about turning
off not turning on well depends if the
line was turn off in advance
yeah it's primarily turn off turn line
cutting cutting out lines yeah yes
to cut the line you redirect the flow
you redirect by redirecting the flow you
know you you you you move congestion you
know you can you can you can reduce
congestion on certain lines and allow
other generators to run so so it's a
matter of by manipulating the topology
you manipulate you redirect the flow and
then you you you can affect the reduce
batch of generators the Khun Tran before
because of a constraint because remember
every line also forms a constraint it's
like when you it's like having a if you
over overload the line it's like having
a short circuit at home so if you cut it
then you eliminate the flow on that line
so you won't have that ones so you
eliminate that constraint well we
actually have a theorem that we show
that in a multi period unit commitment
when you optimize over multiple time
even without congestion you can benefit
from changing the topology and I won't
going through that so this is a we have
a two period example and showing if you
have one period no congestion or benefit
from disconnecting but in a two period
optimization you can have benefit from
changing topology even without
congestion well I mean if you have a
radial connection to a wind farm I mean
obviously you you may not but you know
it's it gets complicated once you start
to have a network it's very hard to
predict so anyway I'll I want to move
faster so this is you know the
formulation of the stochastic unit
commitment you have system and market
clearing price a clearing constrain DC
power flow
line capacity a constraint number of
lines that can be switched off so we
actually put a limit on the number of
lines that can switched off as a way of
pruning the tree because if you know
we're going to put a binary variable on
every transmission line and we you know
that becomes horrendous combinatorial
problem so one way to control the the
complexity of the problem is to say okay
we are going to find the five best line
to switch and order this ten best line
to switch and this reduces the
complexity
we have generation capacity constraint
being up and down min up and down on/off
now again this is an approximation DC
power flow in fact once you find the
solution you have to test it whether it
will be valid in an AC formulation and
sometimes it's not so so there is always
a second stage to test the validity of
what you're trying to do but for this is
what we're trying to do this is the the
way you formulate the topology control
problem basically you relax there is a
this is there is a potato formulation
the usually you have that the flow is
the susceptance times the line the phase
angle difference between the two nodes
on an edge and what we want is to we
have a binary variable R that says
whether the line is in or out if the
line is out then this becomes 0 the flow
becomes 0 but you also have to relax
this constraint because you have to
allow the angles on the two edges to
kind of move certain independently and
you use the Big M formulation to do that
so so this is the the what we do to
replace the this constraint in the power
flow there is an alternative formulation
that uses a flow cancellation where you
keep the system intact you don't cut a
line but instead you find a
configuration of transactions that input
in injection and ejections
that if you execute them it will make
the flow on that line zero and that's an
alternative formulation a finding those
configuration is a fairly complicated
complicated problem if you're only going
to switch a small number of lines it may
work out once you try to switch more
than a certain number of lines then the
computational effort becomes but but
this is I just want to make you aware
there's an alternative formulation I
won't use that this is the network that
we are trying to test our project on it
Hanna need a standard I Triple E honey
native 18 bus system 186 line 19
conventional generators and we have a
wind farm that we tried to put the
different locations in other word where
was the location on here 89 or something
80 626 so so the wind farm is that no 26
here I cannot see it's actually I guess
it's I guess it's here so when so we saw
that step the test problem and we do
some simulation now in order to be able
to do you need to generate scenarios win
scenarios and the way we generate so we
generate a high thousand win scenarios
by starting with an annual data set from
NREL they have data sets of poor Emily
location giving us at 8700 the wind
speed for every hour of the year and
then what we do we do kind of a
bootstrapping where we extract the
systemic fluctuation and in a fittin re
my model so that we end up with white
noise and then we replicate that white
noise realization by simulating aim and
then reconstructing the scenarios so
that we have the same statistical
properties but multiple realizations of
the wind
so this is the way you generate win
scenarios em and then once you have this
the Winston are your speed you can
convert it to power by using a static
power curve conversion which converts
wind speed to power so this is the kind
of day now to solve that problem you
know it has 48,000 binary variables
80,000 continuous variables we solve it
on a laptop a with with a mid gap of 5%
it took us more than eight hours so
that's not not not good so what we had
to do is we developed a warm start a
heuristic which essentially we get the
solution started and this is the you
know the worst start is basically done
by using a stylist regular stochastic
unit commitment without apology control
and then using the topology control for
the most loaded hour and then kind of
mixing them and using that as the
starting point for all the other hours
and that reduced our computation to less
than an hour for for this problem so we
use the simplex and then you know the
idea is that you can use warm start in
the realistic system by looking at the
dispatch the day before M so when so
this is them you know kind of I want to
go quickly through that because I'm
running out of time I actually ran out
of time right five minutes okay so I'm
so I'm not going to you know we actually
did the whole thing you know this shows
the effect of cost so you with
constraints on the number of lines that
you switch so this shows that even if
you with four line or three lines which
is you pretty much realize up to when we
had like they're about fifteen percent
cost reduction in the dispatch that's a
lot of money in a realistic system and
now when we did the same thing and I'm
going to switch
through the reason that we you know when
we used when we don't have a constraint
we use a land limited number of lines
which is we didn't achieve the same mid
gap so kind of the cost went back up but
you know this with 10 10 10 lines
switching we got a pretty good the
significant reduction in cost now just
to go quickly we were trying to track
down where where the cost a reduction
comes from and it comes from for area we
reduce the production cost by switching
generators that are going to be run we
reduce the startup costs by starting
generators that are less that it costs
less to start them the another generator
were able to reduce the no load cost
which is the jump in cause when you know
even if you don't have any load and we
reduce the cost of load shedding and we
did kind of a dissection of you know
where the cost savings is coming for EM
I you know we did the same thing with a
European model of the European system
and then let me just jump to that
we have a European model with a thousand
lines 679 buses seven countries
sixty-six sixty-seven conventional units
and so on and this is the exam you know
this is this is all of Europe we got a
data set and we solve the prom there now
in order to be able to solve it we have
to do some sort of the composition where
we solve the topology control by country
and then but we were able to demonstrate
also a significant cost savings I'll
jump to the last part is that the
composition is the long talk and so when
the last thing that I'm going to talk
about was a flexible line rating so the
flexible line rating the idea is that
the line constraints are coming from the
fact that when the line heats up it
starts to sag it can hit a tree
you put a limit on how much how much you
can transfer through a line now but that
you have to recognize that this happens
there is some thermodynamics involved
there so if you look at the physics this
is the heat transfer equation that shows
the rate of heating of the line which is
a function of the current square times
the resistance of the line and of course
it's also affected by ambient condition
and so on so it means that idea that
what's happening is that this is the
line is actually I'm trying to jump that
the line is going to heat up slowly this
means that for a show for a debate that
you can run the line hot with a high
current for a limited amount of time as
long as you are going to then reduce it
and maybe either leave it at normal
constraint or actually reduce the
constraint we kind of took it so what
you're going to end up is that the
constraint is going to look like that
you know you can choose when you're
going to how you're going to move this
step but it means that you can run the
line at this temperature and then allow
it to run for short periods of time and
then and then then you have to reduce it
after that and give it a cooling period
and then you can do that again
so this means that you introduced binary
variables saying the line can run it hot
can run cold or can be cut off
completely and then we did that and
basically you do again the the
formulation you use it as a recourse
action and you formulate it and what you
achieve by doing that this is a hedging
mechanism against the uncertainty of the
wind so by doing that then you can be
more aggressive on work on you know
dispatch cheaper they had generators so
the benefit accrues most of the benefit
accrues in that they had dispatch
because you know that you have a
recourse action that you can rely on in
the in the second stage
so we're I'm so this is kind of to
illustrate how how things happen so this
is the normal rating and then they you
know so usually this doesn't make any
difference
in most cases this is the red represents
what you do when you do they with the
flexible rating this is what you do it
normal without flexible rating with
normal stochastic unit commitment the
place where you save the money is here
because you see because of this little
spike here that penetrates through the
normal rating that would have resulted
in you having to dispatch a completely
new generator and reroute it completely
from the other and that can start other
generator which can cost a fortune so by
recognizing that you have that
flexibility to run the line hot for a
short period of time and relax the
constraint for that period we have saved
quite a bit of money and that that's
that's how we we achieve that so I think
I'm going to stop here because I'm
running out of time and so basically
this is another example where you can
just have a little penetration through
the through the constraint for short
periods of time which is enabled by by
this flexible rating so the conclusion
is the topology control and flexible
writing can both reduce the operating
cost flexible transmission network
control can mitigate the variability of
renewables generation so the cheaper
slow generators can be committed in the
first stage thank you
yes at least from my experience in my
Nobles they typically they take they're
based on a flexible cost so they basis
they dispatched at any point as long as
does not below zero or negative twenty
dollars so I agree with you that you
could dispatch more thermal wrapping if
a structure but I think where where we
talk mean you know most of the places
renewables are kind of a mistake if you
look in Europe for example I mean they
have feed-in tariffs most wind
generators they put the power and I say
dispatch me as long as the power doesn't
drop a load negative 22 dollars as long
as the price yeah so they have so-so in
Texas they have negative prices for yeah
that that's a good thing California also
has negative prices so that that's
that's one way to control but the point
here is that you know that may be the
solution you see I haven't talked about
the pricing I've talked about if you
look at it from the System Operator
point of view the prices comes after
that how we're going to do but this is
kind of the welfare maximization we are
dispatching the system we're trying to
look at what can you do optimally if you
dispatch the system so as to maximize
social welfare and what we're doing here
is that if you're going to treat the
transmission system as being flexible
you can achieve a higher level now again
how you're going to divide the pie and
how you're going to price their thing
that's a secondary problem and that's I
didn't address it here yes
how would you accommodate the
transmission right owner if you switch
off their life
well you know the ISO is basically
controlling the network they can give
them orders the only problem that line
switching is creating and we when we did
our arpa-e project that's why we kind of
backed off from the idea of doing
transmission switching for economics is
that it screws up the forward
transmission rights market the FDR
market because you reroute you have an
FDR market and people are by rights on
lines on a point-to-point and now you
change the topology and that can make
them lose money so this is this is this
has been a problem you know from my
point of view is that you shouldn't you
know you should do the right thing even
if you know in the market should follow
but not everybody agrees but that's why
here we focusing on using the the line
switching in recourse now this is
something you know once you have
contingencies you know then the ISO
basically has full authority so you can
run the lines at emergency ratings for
30 minutes you can switch lines you can
do whatever action it takes to mitigate
contingencies so we are trying to
recognize that here and say okay if you
are anticipating that you know that
you'll be able to mitigate contingency
with those action how can you save money
in the day ahead stage and that's what
we are doing
if that's they you know this this can be
another variable I have another student
that works on that of trying to impose
some cartel ability of renewable saying
that you can turn you know when win you
can turn the pitch of the of the blades
or with solar you can I don't know have
covered cover your solar panels but yeah
that would be another mechanism so you
know I mean this is a this is a
simplified problem I mean if you really
want to solve the full problem you have
to have in your meeting you know all
these other actions that I pointed out
as ways to achieve flexibility have all
to be considered in the portfolio of
recurse actions that you can use yes
well as I said that PJM were kind of
aiming when we did the topology control
project we say at any point you can
switch one line per day which would be
the best line to switch and just this
capability save a hundred million
dollars in the simulation so so you I
mean there is always an and from all our
experiment all our tests we see that
typically with one two or three lines
you basically achieve most of the
benefit so as I said PJM has a list of
135 lines that can be they use it
primarily for voltage control for other
actions but you know with now in the old
days they used to build transmission
just for reliability now we're building
transmission for economics with building
redundancy in the transmission line
using economic criteria not just
reliability so if you are going to build
transmission for economics you should be
able to consider these disconnecting
lines for economics
and that's what we're doing well M no
we're actually looking the other way
we're looking at how to you know the
question is how fast this happens yeah
but you know presumably it can and we
haven't done that what we are looking at
which is Giorgio is working on how to
allocate Blackstar capability throughout
the network and restoration strategy how
to restart the system from zero which
effectively it's the reverse problem
instead of cutting lines you keep adding
lines in order to energize the system
when you start from zero state and
that's that's another interesting
problem very challenging the only way we
solve that is by you know we have good
friends at Lawrence Livermore that gives
us access to their supercomputer so a
lot of our effort is really on trying to
parallelize a lot of things I mean in
this case we didn't try to op you know
it wasn't focusing so much on an
algorithm but rather focusing on the
capability of what we can achieve with
these strategies but the algorithms
you know it's an you know how do you we
just build algorithms to be able to get
some solute feasible solutions but the
algorithmic part I think that that's
where a lot of the effort should go and
trying to parallelize a lot of this
computation figuring out ways to use a
thousand course in order to address
those prom because you know think about
your PC ten years ago I mean ten years
from now you'll have a thousand cores in
your PC yes
well this is something that it's legal
as a recourse if you look at noir
criteria they have they allow you to run
30 minutes of emergency rating which is
30% about the line limit so so again by
consider it as a recourse action that we
can get away with it it but but
definitely you have to deal with Newark
mmm you know constraint but they they do
allow emergency ratings for meet a
communication of contingencies whether
they willing to consider when the
realization is a contingency that may be
a different issue
[Applause]